gleich zweimal klang sie allein diese
Woche ganz anders als der Kanzler einmal
am Dienstag in Straßburg
AGA wir kämpfen einen Krieg gegen
Russland sagt sie aber meint es nicht so
wie ihr Haus wenig später erklärt keine
Korrektur kommt derweil letzten Sonntag
nach dem gemeinsamen Ausflug nach Paris
während er sein Einverständnis zu
kampfpanzerlieferung da noch verweigert
verkündet sie fast zeitgleich im
französischen Fernsehen man werde
Lieferungen andere nicht blockieren und
sei nicht im Moment wo man mit dem
Finger auf andere zeige sondern
gemeinsam müsse man nun alles tun damit
die Ukraine diesen Krieg gewinnt nicht
auf andere zeigen und die Ukraine müsse
gewinnen ein Schwur den der Kanzler
steht vermietet für viele kleiner als
das nach Belehrung mehr noch nach dem
Sound all jene die Scholz Isolation
vorwerfen und führungsverweigerung die
ignorant finden was er steht so nennt
immer
besonders wenig zu spüren jedenfalls war
wieder mal von dem was man sich
vorgenommen hatte Außenpolitik aus einem
Guss ich glaube es war noch nie in der
deutsche Bundesregierung in der
Außenpolitik so uneinig wie diese
innerhalb der Parteien gibt es
erhebliche Unterschiede bei der SPD z.B
aber auch zwischen Kanzler und
Außenministerin wird nicht die gleiche
Politik betrieben und das schwächt
Deutschland als man begann war die Welt
eine andere der Stellenwert von
Außenpolitik auch Differenzen fanden
keine große Beachtung jetzt ist das
anders der Kanzler lässt oft
kommunikative Lücken ob durch
schuldhaftes Zögern wie Kritiker meinen
oder durch kluge Weitsicht wie man im
Kanzleramt glaubt es gibt sie die Lücken
und in die stößt sie immer wieder hinein
die Außenministerin hat eine sehr
ambitionierte Agenda gerade in den
letzten Jahren ist der die Außenpolitik
in Deutschland nicht zwingend aktiv
gewesen proaktiv gewesen das hat sie
dankenswerterweise verändert
aktiv oder aktionistisch Beispiel Iran
dass sie hier wahrnehmbarer sei als der
Kanzler diege vor allem daran dass der
fast gar nicht sage heißt es aus der
Opposition
substanziell kommen auch von bärbock
wenig auch bei ihrem Herzensprojekt der
sogenannten feministischen Außenpolitik
ich finde das sobald es darauf ankommt
die Grundsätze von feministischer
Außenpolitik von wertebasierte aus
Politik ganz schnell über Bord geworfen
werden das sehen wir im Fall
Waffenlieferung an die Türkei oder auch
in Saudi Arabien dass da eben dann doch
die Bündnis Interessen die Interessen
auch der Rüstungsindustrie höher wiegen
beide stimmten sich bestens ab betonen
Grüne und SPD bloß das ist nach außen
oft gegenteilig wirkt Beispiel China
kurz nach schießt wieder weil reiste der
Kanzler nach Peking Kritik ihren gab es
viele schon verabt die meist beachtete
kam von ihr diplomatisch verpackt zwar
dafür mit Arbeitsauftrag an den eigenen
Chef
der Bundeskanzler hat den Zeitpunkt
seiner Reise entschieden und jetzt ist
entscheidend die Botschaften die wir
gemeinsam festgelegt haben im
Koalitionsvertrag auch in China deutlich
zu machen der Bundeskanzler hat
Ermahnungen von keiner Seite notwendig
erweist sehr genau das ist darauf
ankommt international mit mit allen
Kräften zusammenzuarbeiten die es eben
möglich machen dass so eine Aggression
wie wir sie jetzt erleben sondern Nähe
im paralistische Aggression dass die
auch zurückgewiesen wird und nun die
nationale Sicherheitsstrategie mehrere
Ministerien erarbeiten darin Leitplanken
für die künftige deutsche
Sicherheitspolitik federführend das
Auswärtige Amt doch es gibt gezere um
Zuständigkeiten nur ein Beispiel der
angedachte nationale Sicherheitsrat nach
amerikanischen Vorbild der Streitpunkt
wem soll er unterstehen dem Kanzleramt
findet sie dem Auswärtigen Amt findet er
auch wenn beide es wortreich umschreiben
meine persönliche Erfahrung der letzten
Jahre war dass ihr Höhe die
Absprache aufgehängt worden ist das so
abstrakter wurde das es ist aber
notwendig dass man so kriegt konkret wie
möglich wird vor allem es ist ein
Querschnittsthema und deswegen ist es
richtig dass so ein Gremium und das
insgesamt die Debatte auch ganz zentral
in der in der Bundesregierung
angesiedelt ist womöglich kommen nun
heißt es aus Regierungskreisen am Ende
gar kein neues Gremium ob das der beste
Kompromiss wäre scheint fraglich aber
vielleicht wäre es der ehrlichste bei
den gewisser Weise Exemplare Stunde für
die Dissonanzen der aktuellen deutschen
Außenpolitik